what's going on everybody welcome to
another python mathematics and finance
indicators tutorial video
in this video we're going to be
discussing price rate of change or
sometimes you'll see it as
rate of change or roc this one's uh
basically enough
to where we can condense it all into one
video so we're going to be covering the
intro how to program in python and then
also how to chart it on this one video
it should be under 10 minutes we'll see
so with that let's go ahead and look at
an example so this will give us a rate
of change and we'll look up for
starbucks and so here's an example
of starbucks and a rate of change of 10
and obviously rated changes on the
bottom we've got rsi up here on the top
and so this is a every basically it's
like the current closing price minus the
closing price from 10 periods ago
divided by the closing price of 10
periods ago so it's
percent change minus the times 100 part
so what we have going on here is you can
kind of see how um
the idea of it is is to predict sort of
directionally it's still an
oscillator so it's not totally trend
predicting and you can draw a zero line
as you know
a clear signal but generally it's you'll
actually notice that it starts going up
or starts going down
uh even prior to price on this long of a
time frame it's not as
useful to have such a low um
rate of change so you would cause it's
very busy if you if you haven't noticed
so
but what we can do is like let's zoom
into like a specific
area and so again here this kind of
it still kind of smooths out these lines
this starts really going up back here
but
kind of matches price i'm trying to find
a good scenario like here or
uh rate of change actually starts going
down before even price starts going down
um so that was a good a good example of
that but
now let me compare it to
a 30 rate of change so let's look at
starbucks again
and this time we'll use a 30 rate of
change and so
just so you can see the difference like
this one
is a lot less noisy right so
as far as being above the zero line i
mean this one held it for
almost as long as the trend occurred and
the same thing below the zero line again
i'll do that for now uh like here
right it's flirting with a zero line all
the way down to the basically the end
and it
finally comes up across the zero line as
a buy signal here
it really holds that buy signal all the
way until right here
which was here so obviously pretty
accurate in that sense
and then immediately tells you you know
a week later probably at this point you
know okay go ahead and come back in and
then again you would have wrote it
continuously all the way up with the roc
of 30. so with that let's look at like
another one let's say
let's look at x on this is obviously the
old one i'm going to go ahead and close
this one now
since i don't really like how noisy it
is but again so here's another example
and exxon's like extremely volatile for
this period
and uh it's obviously a lot of ups and
downs here
it seems to be fairly uh accurate even
on exxon but this would be obviously a
pretty hard one but at least where it
was like really noisy here
it was pretty much accurate you know
until pretty much give you the sell
signal here
which is here and it didn't give you the
buy signal
it's pretty much back here so that was a
pretty successful trade
here probably wasn't the best you made a
little bit of money if you traded it
um and so on let me look at let's look
at like maybe one more
maybe ebay or 30.
okay so there's ebay and again um pretty
darn accurate
uh as far as uh with the rs roc 30 and
one
just to give you an idea we're looking
at 10 years of data and i'm pretty sure
each plot
each bar right consists of three days
worth of data
so really this is like an roc 90 right
so
just keep that in mind like 90 days
worth of data anyway
that's that let's go ahead and get into
calculating it luckily it's pretty easy
to calculate
since it's so simple so for this one
instead of calculating it separately
let's just calculate on the actual
uh chart itself so if you don't already
have the chart data
either click the link in the description
or go to centex.com and click on
tutorials
and then scroll down to the programming
stock forex futures options indicators
and displaying them
scroll down some more and we want sample
code with empty slot
click on that scroll down and here is
our sample code
so we'll just copy and paste that copy
copy copy move it over here paste it in
scroll up just a little bit to where we
have this open area
and we're ready to rumble so now what we
want to do is let's go ahead and define
roc and that's going to be the name of
our rate of change
and then we're going to have two
parameters one will be the prices and
for this we'll be using closing prices
and the other parameter will be tf for
time frame we will return
a list of roc for now it's empty we will
populate it and
x is going to equal time frame so that
we can do the following while
x is less than the length of cp
do something so we'll run this while
loop and then what we're going to do is
we're going to say
rocs equals and then in parentheses
again it's new minus the old divided by
the old
so it would be cp so where we are at the
closing price
so the cp of x right so cp is a big list
of prices right so we want the x
number in that list minus the cp
x minus tf because it's price rate of
change from x periods ago so
uh in this case it would be even though
it's like i shouldn't have said x
periods ago
let's say time frame periods ago and
then
it will be uh divided by again
so it's uh you know new the current
price minus the old the one
x time frames ago uh divided by
cp x minus tf right
you could do times 100 to get the full
you know effective times 100
or times 100 times 100 to get like an
actual percentage but it doesn't matter
you're going to be looking at the same
line so next we would say roc dot
append rocs and then x plus equals 1.
and that would be it once we exhaust
that while loop what would we want to do
well we want to return
roc now we can actually come down here
and we can say we'll say r capital r
lowercase o capital c equals
roc and the closing prices
and then we can say whatever time frame
we want
uh i kind of liked the 30 with the 10
years worth of data so we'll do that
um and then
we'll call uh the plotting of it so it's
going to be ax2.plot
and we plot date minus sp colon if you
want to know why we're doing that check
out the python
uh turning stocks in python tutorial
series
and then so that's the x variable the y
one will be r o c
minus s p it stands for starting point
and then we want this line to be white
line so we'll just put a w
next so we can compare easy uh we're
gonna say ax2.grid
true with a color of
white and then we're going to add that
horizontal line that we had
at the zero mark so it'll be ax2.8xh
line so axis horizontal line where do we
want to draw that line at the zero
and then what color do we want it we're
gonna make it cyan
and don't forget an equal sign
so that's all we really have to do um
i will the example code usually i put it
up on my website but just in case you
didn't catch it you can pause the video
now it's nice and big i forgot to make
it big before starting the recording
uh so pause it there if you got behind
now we're ready to chart it so let's go
ahead and actually
actually let's oh we need one more thing
plot dot y label
and this one is an arrows oops rotc
roc 30 and
the color is white save that run that
and stock to plot we'll plot jp morgan
and looks like jp morgan worked out for
us very few signals but it worked at
least
uh so let me drag it over here okay
so obviously here all the way until this
point so
pretty much right at the crossover uh
you got the buy signal a little bit
earlier than the actual uh
simple moving average crossovers uh but
then you got the sell signal right about
the same time it looks like
um yeah this was pretty volatile let's
look at another one
let's say uh bank of america merkel
bring this over
look at the spike here that's pretty
crazy
that was a late one too very late still
it was like still pretty uh bearish at
this point
because that spike it like distorted the
rest of it let's chop that spike off
um anyway you guys could play with it a
little more you can change up
the uh the actual time frame that you
want to use for it
uh but anyway uh that is rate of change
in python and matplotlib hopefully you
guys learned something new hopefully you
enjoyed
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time